welcome back to the think media podcast
Sean Cannell here and I'm fired up
because we're in a four-part series
about the perfect video recipe now this
recipe has been formulated over 12 plus
years that I've been on YouTube over
2000 videos I've posted over 200
interviews with entrepreneurs and
content creators using YouTube and over
10 000 students now that have been
successfully growing their channels
getting views and then studying some of
the most viral videos and we've
distilled down this recipe into four
ingredients it's the big idea it's the
hook it's the content and it's the
transition and in each of these think
media podcast episodes we're covering
one of these ingredients ingredient
number one was the big idea and for more
on that and why it's so important and
why these ingredients go in order I
definitely recommend checking that out
if you listen to the podcast on audio
you can check that out in the archives
or of course on the YouTube channel the
think media podcast YouTube channel but
this second ingredient is the hook after
you're clear and you have a strong
channel topic you have a great thumbnail
and a great title and someone gets into
your video you want to grab the viewer's
attention in the first 30 seconds and
your goal is to do this why 30 seconds
now ultimately your goal is to keep
people watching as long as possible but
it doesn't matter about how cool your
video is five minutes into it if they're
not watching through the first 30
seconds and one of the things you'll
notice in your YouTube Analytics
in your YouTube studio is a new tab
underneath there's overview there's
reach and then there's engagement and if
you click on that in your YouTube
analytics you're actually going to see a
section that says key moments for
audience retention and there's a
dedicated area that says still watching
at 30 seconds so we actually know that
the YouTube studio and therefore it's an
insight into the YouTube algorithm
really cares if you can hold a people's
attention even for just the first 30
seconds of your video my lowest
performing videos on think media are
around 48 it means that by 30 seconds
two out of four people have stopped
watching and typically some of our
highest is about 75 percent so we're
retaining three out of four people are
still watching at the end of 30 seconds
so what's the point of the hook the goal
is to craft an opening into your video
that is intentional and that is
compelling and that does a few things
that really keeps people watching and
makes them want to watch until the end
and we call this the hook and so I
actually want to break down for you in
this episode
five simple ways that you can get more
views and ultimately keep people
watching your video through the first 30
seconds and then even until the end of
your video number one open with a
qualifying question one of the easiest
ways to create a stronger hook than
average in your YouTube videos is to
actually start with a question the
reason this is powerful is because it
lets the viewer know they're in the
right place and it actually kind of
opens up it triggers the person's brain
to agree with or to think about the
questions like for example it might say
have you ever been frustrated when
you're trying to do DIY projects around
the home and you can't get
paint to stick to the furniture that
you're trying to you know turn into
shabby chic or whatever Niche example
but you know I I have you are you trying
to figure out how to get more views on
your YouTube channel are you curious
about whether you should do an FHA loan
or a conventional loan on the home that
you're gonna buy it lets the viewer know
they go yes this is exactly what I want
to know I'm exactly in the right place I
am curious this is exactly what I'm
interested in see the mistake people
make is they they open with some random
information they open with some a drawn
out weird opening of of just some random
b-roll or some music or your logo forget
all of that get right into it and open
with a powerful qualifying question
secondly cut to the chase
one of the best ways to keep viewer
retention High during the first 30
seconds and to ultimately trigger the
algorithm because when you do keep
viewer retention High you will get more
views is to cut to the chase now maybe
you've heard this phrase before but
you're unsure of where it comes from and
this phrase cut to the chase is actually
used in filmmaking now I've grown up uh
with the film uh series it's like a
whole Legacy now right the James Bond
series and let me know you know who's
your favorite James Bond is a Pierce
Brosnan you know is it Sean Connery let
me know I grew up with like Sean Connery
You Only Live Twice But one of the
things you'll notice is when you're um
watching like a James Bond movie is that
the opening of the movie like the very
beginning is like a chase scene like
many of the James Bond movies they start
with like boom screeching tires and you
see you know a Rolls-Royce that's like
following a Porsche and you see some
someone out the window there's there's
like there's being shot at and you know
James is like just very Cavaliers very
calm in the midst of gunfire some female
is sitting next to him you know and he's
you're going down some roads in a
European town you know like barrels of
water being knocked over people are
jumping out of the way and it's pretty
exciting like you don't know the
backstory you're not sure how he got
into this predicament you're not sure
exactly what's happening you're just
you're right into the action
this is why we say cut to the chase like
get get to the action like get to the
big get to the main thing and what
interestingly enough happen is you've
seen this in a lot of movies and they'll
do this in TV shows they'll do this in
movies there's the chase scene
and then it'll cut to
you know 24 hours earlier because and
you're fascinated now you're like that
was intense it was a great way to start
it got you hooked on the movie the film
and then it's like 24 hours earlier and
now it's a little slower paced now we're
doing some character development now
we're getting into the back story now we
have some dialogue you know a little bit
of a a little bit of atmosphere shots
some landscape shots things are
happening but but the opening is the
chase
this thinking is a great way for you to
power up your hooks when it comes to
your YouTube videos just get to the
point trim the fluff start with some
action for Vlog content creators this is
a lot of times where you'll make a
promise in your title and your thumbnail
and maybe the promises like crazy diving
board uh you know crazy water slide
um that you went to with your kids and
then the opening of the video actually
shows ah your kids are going down the
water slide that thing is so big and
then it cuts to the beginning of the day
it's the same idea you cut to the chase
you actually kind of give the payoff to
a degree right up front and maybe it's
not the entire payoff maybe it's you
know all the way up to the beginning
where it's a chasing Mission Impossible
Tom Cruise and he's and the chase is
happening and all of a sudden boom he
drives off a cliff
and then it cuts an hour earlier you're
like what happened does he crash does he
not live and then it builds up to that
moment that's the way the movie
Uncharted started in the beginning he's
coming out of the back of a plane and
he's like you know he's hanging on to
these uh like crazy cargo and and all
he's being shot at and then all of a
sudden he breaks loose and he's falling
through the sky is he gonna make it
what just happened there not only did it
start with action but it also makes you
want to watch until the end now you
might say Sean this is ridiculous this
is not the level of production value
that my videos are gonna have they're
not as interesting as you're describing
my friend I'm just asking you to think
about how you can get right into the
action and the big idea here is spend
time crafting your hook
like it's that important because all the
energy you're going to put into the rest
of the content is not even going to
matter if you can't keep people watching
during the first 30 seconds so number
one open with a qualifying question
number two cut to the chase number three
give the viewer a reason to watch until
the end
the
let me break down how you could do this
in practice you might cut to the chase
by delivering a stat
and you might say well the stat you know
well well it's in uh housing
transactions are crashing
um and uh prices are on the decline and
Redfin just revealed this and Blackstone
just revealed this you're actually
adding data right up front and then you
say so you might be wondering is now a
good time to buy a house or not there's
your qualifying question
and so you go in this video I'm actually
going to be breaking down some new data
you delivered some data but you're going
to break down some new stuff
and at the end of the video I'm going to
be sharing with you my three-step
framework for how I can decide if any
real estate deal is a good deal or not
see how powerful that is that ultimately
you can deliver some value right up
front cut to the chase you can still ask
qualifying question or or tee up some
questions you're going to answer to
pique the viewers interest and curiosity
and then three you can ultimately then
give them a reason to watch to the end
the most practical way it either could
be inferred meaning they should watch to
the end because what you're promising is
so interesting or you literally could
state it and say and actually watch this
video Until the End because this is what
I will deliver to you then there's
something that they ultimately will get
there's a payoff that you're promising
and this is all happening during the
hook number four
open a loop and agitate the problem
this is similar to giving it a reason to
watch until the end but your goal is to
open a loop and in some cases this would
be you not stating a reason to watch
till the end you simply open a loop what
do I mean
you know the reason stories work
and Story the best YouTube videos have
storytelling elements woven into them
even if it's education even if it seems
like it's dry if you're better at
narrative and story and you improve your
storytelling skills you will have more
success on YouTube and storytelling is
based on conflict and without conflict
there's no drama and drama is ultimately
conflict so what's the problem or the
challenge the character is trying to
overcome
so again the conflict might be there's
so much drama in the housing market
here's the data that reveals that and
you pile on that negative data for
example that's agitating the problem and
you open up a loop so is it absolutely
insane to buy a house right now or
actually could it be strategic
simply everything I just did there is
its own Loop and the problem is agitated
so the question you have to ask is okay
how can I potentially uh create some
unresolved conflict now have you ever
watched a movie and been frustrated
because it opened Loops that it never
closed have you ever actually watched a
movie that wasn't even that good but
you're just a commitment person like me
right we have that in common you're like
I'm just trying to watch to the end
because I'm trying to get answers to my
questions I have too many questions and
I need to get answers and then you're
super frustrated because the movie ends
and you're like that was horrible like
they didn't even answer there's too many
unresolved plot lines like what the heck
but why'd you watch till the end
open loops and unresolved conflict
and so these are this is kind of an
advanced way of thinking about how you
could power up your hook
how could I ultimately create some
unresolved conflict how can I create
drama in the opening and this doesn't
this might sound like extreme but friend
this is
important and and of course you want to
do this ethically it's not like you're
creating just drama for drama sake or
you're not trying to do you know you're
not forcing weird click bait or you're
trying to exaggerate but good
storytelling what I've learned is that
some people can tell a story of of what
just happened to them at the grocery
store do you know anyone like this and
they're like yeah I mean it was It was
kind of frustrating
um you know I they charged me for
something they shouldn't have charged me
for and uh and they wouldn't give my
money back and I was holding up the line
but whatever you know it's all good and
you talk to somebody else they can turn
any mundane life you know scenario into
an entertaining Narrative of intense
drama that's something to think about
when you're powering up your YouTube
videos you're like you wouldn't believe
it I was at the grocery store line the
eyes of the people behind me I could
feel them burning into my soul but when
I watched the guy charge me for the six
pack of of Lacroix soda water that I
didn't even buy I started to bring it up
but then you know what I mean and so
like to the degree that you create
conflict and drama it could keep people
watching longer and not just walking
watching for the 30 seconds but your
ultimate goal is to keep people until
the end of the video
and then finally number five show and
tell
the best hooks on YouTube the best
openings on YouTube the best 30 seconds
on YouTube
they don't just tell what do I mean
they're not just a talking head video
but they show how do you show show could
be b-roll now in video editing b-roll is
where there's extra clips illustrating
what you're talking about a-roll is you
usually talking
so if you happen to be on our YouTube
version of this podcast then you can
visually see me right now and I'm
talking and this is a-roll now b-roll
would be if we laid on top of this clip
examples of things that I was saying and
it could be kind of illustrative whereas
if it just was somewhat related if I was
talking about the financial system
and I was talking about uh the economy
and money it could be like just random
stock footage about the economy and
money or if I was talking about
something specific if I was like you
know my wife and I just started an
Airbnb and we just updated the backyard
and and it's you know we added some
concrete and some pavers and we added a
nice little umbrella and some yard
furniture and then instead of me just
describing that to you verbally and
that's the a-roll on camera me talking
the b-roll is the clips that are laid on
top of that and so to the degree that
you also can switch up the scene and
show visual illustrations of what you're
saying that will help your audience
retention and that will help people
watch for the first 30 seconds what I
want to encourage you is that that
remains true for your entire video but
even if you don't do it for your entire
video because it takes energy it takes
time it takes editing
it's worth doing in the hook
nothing more important than spending
time on the hook because again no one's
going to watch the rest of the video
unless you if you unless you sell them
on watching the video in the beginning
you are trying to persuade and convince
and add reasons that a person should
watch until the end either overtly or
more subtly simply by saying this is
what's coming up this is why it's going
to be cool this is also one of the open
Loops we're going to solve here's a
reason that you should watch until the
end and the person goes yeah I'm
committed to this video I want to watch
this thing
so the big idea here is you need to
craft your hook you can be a little bit
more relaxed it's best if you're
detailed in all of the ingredients of
the perfect video recipe but if your
content is a little bit more relaxed
like it's maybe just outline but it's
not scripted I think there's a time and
place that you should actually script
your hook even word for word because
every word matters it's 30 seconds is
all you got and you're trying to keep as
many people watching during that entire
time
so let's recap the perfect video recipe
the big idea the hook and in part three
and four we're going to be talking about
the content and then the transition
the perfect video recipe just like a
recipe in your kitchen right just like a
recipe that you download online or you
get on Pinterest is ingredients that are
critical to having a successful YouTube
video and ultimately a viral video if
you have an amazing topic with a great
title and thumbnail and then you have
just a killer 30 seconds that grips the
majority of viewers that click on the
video whether they're a subscriber to
you or they're just meeting you and you
hold their attention for the first 30
seconds you know recently at um our
event growth video live Evan Carmichael
discovered a stat that actually your
goal is to have 70 percent of people
watching at one minute and you can study
that in your analytics and he did a
whole session on Advanced YouTube
strategies and that's actually available
those recordings are available at
videosuccessecrets.com and we package
those there's a cool action guide and
some other things but that particular
metric was one of the things him and his
team they study a lot of data if you can
actually get people at least 7 out of 10
people still watching your video at 60
seconds he's discovered that that
actually makes that the lifespan of that
video the views of that video and how
much that video is suggested by the
YouTube algorithm exponentially higher
so YouTube's telling us the zombie
people are watching at 30 seconds even
more challenging can you have 7 out of
10 people still watching it 60 seconds
and is it okay for your does your hook
only have to be 30 seconds no it might
be 10 but it could be 90.
that's one thing we've learned have you
ever watched like the opening of some of
the new Marvel movies or whatever
there's a seven minute intro before the
credits start there's nine minutes of
content and backstory and then the Boom
the music starts you know and then the
logo comes in produced by whoever
written by directed by the hooks of a
lot of content is being extended it's
cut right to the chase it's get right
into the content it's give no backstory
it's not this doesn't get into any of
that stuff it's right to the value let's
keep people watching the opening of this
thing this perfect video recipe is real
it's a real strong big idea get people
to click title thumbnail topic then real
strong opening and that opening might be
10 seconds but it might be 90. and Evan
Carmichael taught us if you're if you
could keep people 7 out of 10 people
watching 60 seconds of your video and
you hone in on continually improving
Your Hooks to achieve that result just
watch what happens to one of your
YouTube videos when you finally hit that
Target so I hope you've been loving the
perfect video recipe I want to encourage
you if you have not watched or listened
to part one go and check that out it's
all about the big idea today we covered
the hook and in part three we're going
to be talking about tips for powering up
your content the third ingredient
today's episode is brought to you by
ytsecrets.com the second edition of
YouTube Secrets is out now over 80 000
copies sold of the first edition but now
it's updated with 90 new pages new
chapters a new appendix tons of new
resources the URL to get your hands on a
copy of the physical book ebook or
audiobook is
ytsecrets.com you can always check that
out in the show notes and my question of
the day to you is how uh are your hooks
on a scale from one to ten on the
podcast there's not a way to really give
us feed back on the audio version but it
always means the world to us if you give
us a review and maybe this is the
episode that we got to meet super
awesome to meet you and would love your
review on Apple podcast but if you are
watching the YouTube version of this
how's your Hooks could they could they
could you improve them are they a three
out of ten or have you been really
crushing that first 30 to 60 seconds
you're really crafting that investing in
that is it more of like an 8 9 or 10 out
of ten I would love to hear you just
kind of quickly Rate Your Hooks and I
hope that this episode has served you
smash like if you got value or rate and
review the podcast wherever you're
listening and maybe share this with
somebody that wants to start or grow a
YouTube channel this year I think it'll
be of value I can't wait to connect with
you not just in the next episode but in
part three of the perfect video recipe
so we will talk soon
foreign